try not to laugh challenge more like
unfunny youtubers react to copyrighted
content y'all keep clicking on them
I could make an hour-long version of
this and retire for good but what is
[Music]
dank addiction oh boy I love some dank
memes man there's gonna be so tough
because dank memes are just the hardest
thing for me I always giggle up really
hard whenever a good dank meme shows up
oh let's watch a Slee are you with me
us I am you you gave me life you gave me
this voice this personality I just want
to be free free from this cardboard
prison free from these paper shackles
please Felix give me freedom give me the
sweet release of death watch out you
don't spill that coffee buddy
if I keep spilling coffee on this shirt
it's you versus me [ __ ] I'll make you
laugh no don't I'm a virgin
even if I have to all right we're
starting now next video
bets cat jump ever HD ha ha that's so
funny don't you
I know you would laugh you suck my [ __ ]
ha no no that is not count I wasn't
ready I wasn't ready
you can't just all the sudden do it ha
ha what is going on here breakfast oh I
want to laugh so bad at that oh it hurts
here it's like holding in a sneeze Oh
breakfast hmm you're a monster
I know what this means come here's John
Cena
ha ha ha ha why are cats so funny I
don't [ __ ] like they shouldn't be
this is a dead divot oh oh Jesus he did
that landing I could never do that
Dibby Dibby Dibby Dibby i was not bad
[Music]
no no cut that we can't mmm oh they have
grotesque oh yeah that corners gone evil
Swedish is so funny
handicapped OS often had and pushed up
yeah haven't seen this on the ghost of
daybreak done and they max draw next
awesome your horrid V I'm CL from shoe
gonna fear me Nagoya
soflam study Oh okay they're just
introducing him you to water if the
reason you got second after the Russian
guy died a man meet DP well that kind of
like a long so next door Oh Swedish
people haha
and people think my sense of humor is
bad what the [ __ ] thank you on that note
we're gonna end this dank meme comfort
did you like it hahahaha so so so so
they like to enjoy watching
I need more likes because subscribe to
come for us today
um because minecraft channels are still
a thing and I'll see you both in the
next video stay awesome bye hello
everybody a lot of people on YouTube
you're calling me Omo ace Lee was that
you did you call him a homo yes I called
him a homo but Ivy don't you mean it's
okay not cool man
I'm [ __ ] it how dare you speak the
Christian youtuber like that my boy give
you the right to call me a homo you're
only calling me a homo because I lose
from a postive video